hi i'm jake gyllenhaal and i am going to
be answering some fan questions while
playing with
puppies
i got the i got the guys i'm trying to
answer a question okay i got a call
from john watts the director and he was
like hey
we're doing the next spider-man movie he
just wanted hi
who's claw the sweater's not a good
thing for your
[ __ ] there you go i got a call from
yeah and he just asked me oh do you want
to play mysterio and i was like
what are you gonna do with him and it
was really cool um
it was a really cool um
i remember tom and i not being able to
hold uh
stop lap we couldn't stop laughing when
we first shake hands in the first scene
where our characters meet
and he was just like constantly uh every
time i would come in and be like
hey how are you i'm quentin he would he
would just start laughing he couldn't
stop and so we both
was 40 takes we couldn't get it in the
movie john watts uses
a millisecond of the shot because he
couldn't get he couldn't get anything
usable
this sweater is destroyed it's done or
it's the new rage
puppy ripped sweater
what show would we do you guys
hey guys
uh something with dancing so he can do a
lot of the dancing and i can
just watch him do cool dancing right you
guys these puppies remind me of tom
holland
if you're talking about who is the
biggest [ __ ]
it would be deadpool uh he'd win that
fight that's basically the only fight
there is isn't there
this sweater is destroyed destroyed
i'm ascended to ryan reynolds and first
you two little guys are gonna pee
and poop all over it and then we're
gonna send it to my friend
ryan
i'd love to see her take on mysterio
that'd be kind of cool she'd probably
rock it
and then i'd be like should have done
that
ah just listen just shut up and listen
that's the best advice i've ever gotten
i played jeff bowman who survived the
marathon boston bombings and he lost
both of his legs
in in the process and um his story
i got to tell and he's become a friend
and that really changed my life working
with him and and
just trying to even recreate his story
and understand how he felt and the
courage that it took to survive what he
survived
changed my life and has changed me as an
actor and also as an individual
i don't watch my movies on repeat every
night
someone once said that i i frame i have
framed posters of myself
it was literally the most absurd thing
i've ever heard and i really love the
process
of making movies and if i'm in them and
i'm producing them maybe like
and part of that post-production process
i love it
um and i can be very objective sometimes
things come on tv and i'm like oh you're
pretty good in that scene but that's
pretty much it
[Music]
i think it's really cool it's a movie
about adolescence you know it's a movie
about
all the difficulties of of growing up
and
growing into this world that's so
confusing and
uh beautiful but uh destructive and
complicated and all those things and
what are you doing i understand there's
sort of a cult falling to it because i
think
there are not a lot of movies about
adolescence that go into like the
mindset of it and all the complications
of it and so
um i i know i don't know
i actually don't know if he dies at the
end i'm not sure
do you guys know what donnie darko is
about
was that a yes
[Music]
i did this movie a long time ago called
moonlight mile as with dustin hoffman
and susan sarandon and holly hunter and
dabney coleman
and just these incredible just behemoths
uh actors of their time and of
there's legends just like four or five
legends
of stage and screen and the the
knowledge that was being thrown at me
constantly i only took about 1 100th of
what i could have
so i wish i could go back and learn even
more from those actors
and from that process it was like it was
the coolest
who cares about theater or movies you
have puppies
the cool thing about doing a theater is
that you're there
at the same place every night and you
get to go do it at exactly the same time
and there's always
an audience there and um they're kind of
waiting and the excitement is like
really palpable and really cool
and i actually will bring my dog
to a theater which is really cool he
spends like
a lot of time backstage he's a real
theater dog
thank you to pacific pups rescue for for
providing these amazing little souls for
me to hang out with
and to smell and you guys are really
sweet and
yeah by the way i think i just ate dog
food
they must have just eaten because i
think i just ate dog food
you